faut-il craindre l'utilisation d'armes
chimiques ou biologiques en ukraine oui
d'après joe biden le président américain
accuse bladimir poutine d'inventer des
menaces de toutes pièces afin de
justifier une future utilisation de ces
armes par l'armée russe
il affirme que les états unis ont des
armes biologiques et chimiques en europe
c'est tout simplement faux je vous le
garantis il suggère aussi que l'ukraine
possède des armes biologiques et
chimiques
cela prouve qu'ils envisagent d'utiliser
les deux il a déjà utilisé des armes
chimiques dans le passé de son côté le
kremlin sûr que la menace vient en
réalité des occidentaux
des spécialistes russes de la protection
nucléaires biologiques et chimiques ont
étudié des documents originaux révélant
détail la mise en oeuvre d'un projet
secret des états unis en ukraine il
s'agit de recherche sur les moyens de
transmettre des maladies à l'homme par
l'intermédiaire de chauves souris dans
un laboratoire de kharkiv
des allégations fermement démenties par
kiev et washington depuis 1997 une
convention internationale dont la russie
est signataire interdit la fabrication
le stockage et l'utilisation des armes
chimiques officiellement la russie
aurait achevé la destruction de ces
armes chimiques en 2017 mais elle est
soupçonnée d'en avoir conserver un stock
de plusieurs milliers de tonnes en
atteste par exemple l'empoisonnement de
plusieurs ennemis du kremlin comme
l'agent double sergueï skripal où
l'opposant politique alexeï navalni tous
deux ont été exposés aux novices choc
une substance neurotoxique d'origine
soviétique
le kremlin qui a toujours nié être à
l'origine de ces empoisonnements est
aussi critiqué pour son soutien sans
faille au régime de bachar el-assad
pourtant accusé d'avoir utilisé des
armes chimiques contre sa propre
population